today on the mat wall show a half naked
pop star desecrates a historical
artifact while the left looks on and
cheers we'll discuss also Biden is now
at the point in his dementia decline
where he is literally seeing ghosts plus
the prime minister of New Zealand says
that misinformation is an act of war in
our daily cancellation a major airline
will now allow allow Pilots to
cross-dress on the job all the name of
inclusivity all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a an easy way to adjust your
spending and saving strategies you just
call my sponsors at American financing
America financing is America's home for
Home Loans where you can get a free no
obligation financial review and learn
new ways to get out of debt faster no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around ways to add hundreds
back to your monthly budget they might
suggest consolidating debt or adjusting
your mortgage terms even accessing cash
either way American financing can help
you you don't need perfect credit to
make it happen they want to help as many
families as possible that's the goal
here which is one of the many reasons I
like them so much it just takes 10
minutes today to learn more and you
can't afford really to not explore every
Avenue to save money and help your
finances you're not getting help from DC
that's for sure so call
866-569-4711 that is again
866-569-4711 or you can visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
182334 at MLS consumeraccess.org
you'll begin to see the world with
greater Clarity things start to make
some kind of sense once you realize and
accept two points about the elites who
run this country
um our Bettors as they see themselves
anyway one is that they hate you and
everything you stand for and everything
you believe this cannot be stressed
enough
it's not a very pleasant thing to think
about but it's the truth
it shouldn't be a Breaking News Bulletin
either I mean after all they're not
exactly trying to hide it they despise
you your family your ancestors on down
the line the second point is that they
are both uh Petty and creative so
they'll take advantage of every
opportunity to humiliate and demoralize
you and they'll see such opportunities
in situations that wouldn't have even
occurred to you okay the pettier the
better as far as they're concerned and
with these two points of mind you can
begin to make sense of a headline that
if you didn't know any better you'd
think was some kind of drunken Mad Lib
but uh here it is from CNN lizzo
performs on stage with James Madison's
200 year old Crystal flute
that's exactly what happened set up
initially by a tweet from Carla Hayden
of the Library of Congress
she posted quote the Library of Congress
has the largest flute collection in the
world with more than 1800 it includes
President James Madison's 1813 Crystal
flute lizzo we would love for you to
come see it and even play a couple when
you're in DC next week like like your
song they are good as hell winky face
emoji now it would be bad enough that
the librarian of Congress is using
emojis and the phrase good as hell in
Communications from official government
accounts but they took it many steps
further a few days later official
representatives from the Library of
Congress along with Secret Service came
up on stage during a lizzo concert in DC
handed her the Priceless historical
artifact and let her do this with it
let's watch it together
okay so there they are Library Congress
they hand her the flute
no big deal she drops it just shatters
and nothing to worry about there
she's in her see-through onesie she's
got the thong on
a wine glass
let's see let's see this performance is
she gonna she's gonna perform a
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
and there's the turkey
there's a turkey
oh she's raising in the air you know
again drop it no big deal
okay
this is uh is actually they've done
studies on this and if you watch
um a lizzo video it's it's a like a
scientifically guaranteed that within 30
seconds of when the video starts she
will be twerking so there's no there is
no footage of her that lasts longer than
30 seconds where she's not twerking
now to make sure that we have the quote
correct for the historical records lizzo
said
I just twerked and played James
Madison's Flute from the 1800s and that
she did
now needless to say there were many
members of the media attending this
concert and they couldn't stop gushing
about the beauty and power and
historical significance of what they
just witnessed now In fairness that is
how they react to literally everything
lizzo does or says if they saw her
eating waffles for breakfast which I'm
sure she does quite frequently they they
would declare it the most Brave and
inspirational waffle related event
they'd ever witnessed if lizzo were to
then burp at the conclusion of her meal
they would tearfully exclaim that her
belch sounded like the choirs of angels
singing from on high this is the rule
the media realizes because lizzo is
obese she's female she's black which
means that everything she does is by
default heroic and wonderful and any
criticism by default is automatically
racist and sexist and body shaming on
top of it so
with that in mind I mean lizzo twerking
in a glittery thong while manhandling a
historic artifact once owned by a
Founding Father well I mean they
literally have no choice but to Crown
such a moment as the greatest
achievement of all time the culmination
of human history the most spectacular
expression of Humanity's potential
just a couple of examples here will
suffice Fox D.C reporter Sierra Fox
tweeted history is freaking cool of
course it's the nation's capital so
Secret Service and Capitol Police joined
her on stage why because she's the first
ever to play President James Madison's
1813 Crystal flute courtesy of Library
of Congress super amazing to witness
then media executive Indira lakshamanan
chimed in with this joyful and
life-affirming Superstar lizzo played DC
tonight most unexpected moment Library
of Congress loaned her President James
Madison's 1813 Crystal flute to play on
stage making her the first person to do
so she thanked Library of Congress for
preserving history and making it cool
and many other tweets and headlines just
like that
now we should note here that lizzo is
indeed a classically trained uh flautist
as as her Defenders have pointed out she
is capable of respectfully and
skillfully playing flute but that's not
what the Library of Congress arranged in
this case or what happened on stage
the fact that she's a in reality a
talented musician at least when it comes
to the flute
just makes her whole career and
especially the incident on stage all the
more outrageous and gross I mean there's
another video floating around of her
playing the flute seriously while fully
clothed that I guess happened before
this or after I don't know they could
have simply left it at that and if you
would complain
but instead they chose to have lizzo in
her see-through thong make a grotesque
mockery of a Priceless Crystal artifact
with deep ties to American history
why I mean what's the point
it's such a weird and Petty thing to do
isn't it
well yes exactly
pettiness is pointed and intentional as
always
this is the game okay they do something
absurd and bizarre and degrading and
then they wait for the reaction that
they know is coming and that's why they
did it and then they accuse the other
side of being petty and trivial so they
do the thing the petty trivial thing and
then if we notice it we are the petty
trivial people
what's more they themselves will then
hail this degrading display uh they'll
they'll declare it to be historic and
important and amazing
but then mock anyone who criticizes it
on the grounds that they shouldn't care
about it because it's unimportant
it doesn't make any sense but this is
the mind game
and it puts us in a bind quite by Design
because if we register our protest you
know if we say anything we say I don't
like this please don't do that
um we will have given them the attention
they want and in a sense you might say
walked right into the [ __ ]
but if we say nothing at all if we
simply accept for instance that
invaluable pieces of American History
can be used as stage props by morbidly
obese half-naked pop stars then we will
have also given them what they want
what they want most of all which is our
acquiescence
our submission
but either way they claim victory which
of course is demoralizing
and in the end ultimately demoralization
is the point
so what the elites want to express when
it comes down to it
whether it's by tearing down statues or
taking names off of schools or doing
anything else they do or having a weirdo
and a onesie twerk with James James
Madison's flute whatever it is what they
want to get across
is that nothing you care about has value
your heritage and history are
meaningless your culture and traditions
are worthless
they will tell you what has value what
you should see as important what should
matter to you
this is what a ruling force does to a
conquered people it tears down and
desecrates everything they hold dear
and it will have achieved its final end
when you submit to the gaslighting and
you finally agree that well these things
don't actually matter
when they've claimed your your mental
and spiritual compliance
and then they really want
which is why we should never submit
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
I also wanted to mention
we'll get off this subject in a moment
but you know it's just what really
annoys me
is that there are plenty of
conservatives online and you always have
these you know useful idiots
who are saying well you know I think
it's kind of cool as they're playing the
flute or or they're or they're doing
what I mentioned before there's oh well
it's a trap
we can't feed into it and act like we
care
we just have to emphasize that okay if
that's if that's what you're going with
then you're just accepting you're just
saying okay you can do that
I mean what take you know take the
Declaration of Independence and use it
as a napkin like yeah give that to her
next next time she is eating waffles you
can use it as a napkin why not you know
but that's cool it's historic and it's
just a p it's just a it's just a it's
just an object who cares
why should we care about that
meanwhile they'll tell you to their face
what they're actually doing so here here
are some uh a couple other tweets I
didn't mention this one is from Tiffany
C lies she's a law scholar she says
lizzo a black female Superstar
collaborating with Carla Hayden the
first African-American and first woman
librarian of Congress to use a flute
from James Madison the founding father
who originated the three-fifth
compromise and also the Library of
Congress itself what symbolism
then she continues James Madison was
America's fourth president he helped
shape the U.S Constitution and the Bill
of Rights he also was a slave owner and
he created the Three-Fifths Compromise
that each enslaved person would count as
a as three-fifths of a person for State
electoral to vote totals a complicated
Legacy now
she's mangling the history with James
Madison in the Three-Fifths Compromise
that's not really the point uh the point
is that what what she is saying and
she's not the only one uh Ellie Miss
style who's a missile however he
pronounced his name you see him on CNN a
lot he says this if any of James
Madison's descendants is offended by
lizzo uh if they want to try try out the
200 year old iron collar white folks
would have fixed to our ancestors who
tried to escape James Madison's clutches
I'm sure somebody at the national museum
of African American history could hook
you up
and a lot of a lot of takes just like
this what are they saying they are
they're clearly saying that the way they
see it
part of the point of this flute stunt
was uh not only demoralization as we
talked about but also very specifically
it's an act of racial retribution it's
sort of like getting back at James
Madison
um for his position on slavery and we're
going to do that by taking a Priceless
artifact that belonged to him and just
making a mockery of it
but sure I mean if you want to be above
it all and say ah who cares whatever
that doesn't matter
you can go ahead and do that
but you are ultimately giving the left
exactly what it wants all right much is
being made of this and uh and for good
reason really Joe Biden at an event
yesterday tried to summon the dead
calling for a congresswoman who had
tragically died in a car accident back
in the summer
and
well well let's play first and then
we'll talk about here it is
representative Jackie are you here
where's Jackie I don't think she uh she
was going to be here to help make this a
reality
uh well again she she's she's dead and
what what makes this worse
is that apparently from what from what
I've uh read anyway
they actually prior to Biden coming out
on stage
they played a a tribute to to this uh
Congress congresswoman who had died
and yet still somehow he was calling for
her
uh even though she's dead
now
as always though the cover-up is worse
than the crime and that was the case
here because Karen Jean pair
was asked about this and you know now
look
In fairness to her and I rarely would
say this but In fairness to anyone who's
tasked with being the White House Press
Secretary for the Biden Administration
anyone who has to represent it or
explain the sorts of things that Biden
does you're in an impossible situation
so we do have to realize that and I know
that on the right we give Karen Jean
pair a hard time and and deservedly so
often
but it is impossible because
like what's the real answer why did that
happen how do you explain that event
well it happened because Joe Biden has
dementia and is losing his mind is
actually losing his his very little
grasp on reality at this point
so that's why that's why it happened and
we all know that
but as White House Press Secretary she
can't really exactly say that so she has
to come up with some sort of excuse
I'm not sure that there's a good excuse
but uh let's go through this this
exchange let's play the first one here
what happened in the Hunger event today
the president appeared to look around
the room uh for an audience member a
member of Congress who passed away last
month he seemed to indicate she might be
in the room so the president was uh as
you all know you guys were watching uh
today's event a very important event on
food insecurity the president was naming
the Congressional Champions on this
issue and was acknowledging her
incredible work he had he had already
planned to welcome the congresswoman's
family to the White House on Friday
there will be a bill signing in her
honor this coming Friday so of course
she was on his mind she was of top of
mind for the president he looks very
much looks forward to discussing her
remarkable Legacy of public service with
them when he sees her family this coming
Friday
okay so she she was top of mind
uh
which now that part you could believe
okay you know she was working on this
issue uh she had just recently died the
terrible tragedy top of mind but then
you see I've
I mean there are many people who have
died who uh I think about and I've never
imagined that they were in the room
and so the media is actually
shockingly not satisfied with that
answer and they and and so now we go
into this this actually goes on for I
don't know 15 minutes where she's going
back and forth not just with well this
isn't like one of those things where
it's just Peter Ducey going back and
forth with Karen Jean pair it's it's
everyone else in the room is uh not
happy with the answer and so we'll go
through not gonna watch the entire
exchange but here's here's uh it
continued here
he said Jackie are you here where's
Jackie she must not be here no I totally
understand I just I just explained she
was on top of mind uh
um you know this wasn't what we were
able to witness today and what the
president was able to lift up uh in this
uh at this conference at this event was
how her uh her focus on um wanting to uh
deal with combat food insecurity in
America and this is something that he
was lifting up and honoring and again he
knows that he's going to see her family
this coming Friday there is a bill
signing that's going to happen in
renaming a VA clinic in in Indiana after
the late congresswoman he knows that he
is going to see her family and she was a
top of mind
she was talking about she's gonna stick
with that what look
what else do you want her to say okay
I'm at you know what I didn't think this
was gonna happen but I am defending
Karen Jean pair on this what do you
there's nothing just there's no good
excuse for this he was trying to conjure
the dead he was he was seeing ghosts
literally do you want her to say that
she can't say that
so this is uh she she before she went
out there you know she's thinking like
what am I going to say about this my God
and this is what she came up with and I
don't know I'm not sure I could have
done any better
what's really significant about this
besides the fact that our that the
president United States has lost his
mind I mean that's that is unfortunately
old news
um what's significant about it
if anything aside from that is just that
again the media
actually asking follow-ups
not accepting the first answer they get
[Music]
um which you don't see very often
so it seems to me now is that because
the media has decided to do their jobs
decided that they're going to have
integrity and uh you know operate with
some journalistic ethics or anything
like that well no of course not it's
just because
you know if if I'm to guess
is that they realize and maybe for a lot
of them the final wake-up moment was
that when they saw him calling for
someone who had died they realized that
they you know this is not going to work
in 2024 they can't go into 2024 with
this guy
and so they're gonna try to take him
down
while there's still time to find someone
else to put there
um so that that I think is what's
actually happening
now so while we're on the subject of
people in the white house uh babbling
I've also had this I wanted to play for
you just because it's a it's fun we
heard from Keisha Lance bottoms a few
days ago she's the new White House
advisor she uh used to be
uh she used to be the mayor of Atlanta
where she did a horrible job and she
oversaw like every other Democrat mayor
in the country oversaw the destruction
over the continued destruction and
collapse of her City and then when she
left she was awarded with this job in
the White House and um it seemed to me
like she spent too much time around
Kamala Harris so listen to this
so can you give me specifics on what
you're doing in terms of that
coordination with other countries
well as you've mentioned we are already
having discussions with other world
leaders and making sure that as we are
dealing with the challenges that we are
facing right now uh that we are also
looking at long-term strategies on how
we can globally work together to address
this issue whether it be migrants coming
into the United States or going into
other countries this is something that
we all have to be thoughtful about and
all work together to address the
challenges and also again remembering
that many of these people may not
necessarily receive asylum in the United
States but also being very thoughtful
that these are families these are women
these are children who are fleeing
communism I don't think anybody wants to
pack up and leave their Homeland and
walk days at a time so it's something
that we know is a crisis and a challenge
that the president is taking head on
and so she's asked about what specific
things
like how are you going to deal with the
illegal immigrant crisis on the border
although they don't say illegal
immigrant things now it's just migrant
um so which by the way that that does
appear to be the new so they've kind of
gotten away from undocumented
immigrants they got away from that now
it's just migrant I'm not exactly sure
well it's just this is how this is how
it works you just change the language
periodically uh even if there's no
particular reason do you change it just
to change it so now it's migrant now
we're allowed to say migrant uh
certainly not illegal though so she's
asked what specific plans does the White
House have you're very critical of what
Ron DeSantis has done you're critical
about what Greg Abbott has done so what
are you going to do and her answer is
that we are already having discussions
with other world leaders and making sure
that as we are dealing with the
challenges that we are facing right now
that we are also looking at long-term
strategies on how we can globally work
together that's
that is uh almost puts Camilla Harris to
shame in terms of
um using the most amount of words to say
the least
so when you look at the kind of inverse
relationship between the amount of words
used and how and what and how much is
actually being said
quite impressive
all right this is from uh daily wire
latest on Hurricane Ian hurricane Ian
slammed into Southwest Florida as a
powerful category for Hurricane
Wednesday afternoon after more than two
million Floridians were given
evacuations order with evacuation orders
with 150 mile per hour winds hurricane
Ian tied for the fourth strongest
hurricane to ever hit the State National
Hurricane Center said that the hurricane
was moving North Northeast approximately
nine miles per hour and uh then was
expected to slow down and turn Northeast
on Thursday uh this has been
by the way another obviously a challenge
for Ron DeSantis as as Governor you know
like when it comes to the the actual Act
of governing
um and uh I think yet again he's hit it
out of the ballpark organizing the
evacuation dealing with all of the
emergency response and everything else
seems like he's done a fantastic job
you're not going to hear that from the
media of course instead they're going to
talk about they don't want to talk about
that they don't want to talk even about
the hurricane itself uh what they want
to talk about is climate change so here
uh is
CNN on that
uh Ian is coming Ian's here John we just
felt that market increase in wind speeds
within the last 10 minutes or so we were
riding about 40 50 miles an hour it's
hard to Fathom that speed tripling in
the next few hours but we're now getting
maybe 70 mile an hour gusts here we're
right at the point where U.S 43 heads
across the Peace River here I'm just in
front of the memorial for Hurricane
Charlie which in 2004 devastated this
town and sent a wake-up call to this
community about the threats of living on
the coast in a rapidly warming Planet uh
as a result of that storm they were the
First Community in Florida to put in a
climate adaptation plan a sea level
Coastal resiliency plan that they're you
know have been working on for years now
and this will be the test
it's hard to build power lines or or
building codes for 17-foot storm surge
though that's the
the crazy variable here right now no one
has ever seen that so we don't know what
that looks like
but this is exactly what
climate scientists have been warning
about for a long time and now we get to
see how it close John
oh now we get to see it up close now we
get to see a hurricane for the first
time we've never seen that before
yeah I I just I I kind of like the
visual there of uh did you see how
useless these people are the hurricane
is it's it's bearing down on you right
now you're in the basically in the
middle of the hurricane
and you're talking about climate change
this this is one of the reasons why
leftists make terrible
leaders they make terrible Governors
they make terrible mayors
they can't run anything because they
can't deal with specific practical
problems
like we talked about yesterday and as uh
someone on CNN had to remind Don Lemon
whatever you feel about climate change
whatever you think about it it's that's
not a useful conversation right now
because right now the hurricane is here
and that's what we got to deal with
okay even if it's true that in theory
you could have passed legislation that
would stop it it's not true that's
absurd but if it is even if it was
that's not going to help us right now
because the Hurricanes here we gotta we
got to deal with that
um so on the left all they ever want to
do they want to have like these abstract
conversations they want to sit around
having abstract conversations about
what's the what's the the root of all
this where is all this coming from I
mean they do this with hurricanes they
do it with crime in the city
and there are times and places for those
conversations
and when it comes to those conversations
they're wrong about everything they say
which is another problem
but when you're in charge of dealing
with it you need to actually be able to
grab you know grapple with the problem
itself on a practical level
so yeah you we could sit around
pontificating about uh the the criminal
justice system and
what leads people to a life of crime why
do you have crime in in so much crime in
some of these communities and less than
others that's we can talk about all that
well the problem is that the people that
run the cities that's all they're doing
is just talking about it
and when you try to get them to focus on
the Practical problem itself what are we
going to do okay yeah you could we could
discuss the roots of it but now we have
the situation right now is that we've
got a lot of dangerous people running
around these cities killing people what
are we going to do about that right now
right now what are we going to do about
it
that's it that's
they're totally eloquent
to talk about that at all
um the New Zealand prime minister has a
solution to climate change herself and
that she laid out to the U.N
um her idea is that uh well if we ban
people from questioning it
that's how we can save lives here and
stop hurricanes let's listen
we launched an initiative alongside
companies and non-profits to help
improve research and understanding of
how a person's online experiences are
curated by automated processes
this will also be important in
understanding more about Miss and
disinformation online a challenge that
we must As Leaders address
sadly I think it's easy to dismiss this
problem as one in the margins I can
certainly understand the desire to leave
it to someone else
As Leaders we're rightly concerned that
even the most light touch approaches to
disinformation could be misinterpreted
as being hostile to the values of free
speech that we value so highly
but while I cannot tell you today what
the answer is to this challenge I can
say with complete certainty that we
cannot ignore it
to do so poses an equal threat to the
Norms we all value
after all how do you successfully end a
war
if people are led to believe the reason
for its existence is not only legal but
Noble
how do you tackle climate change if
people do not believe it exists
how do you ensure the human rights of
others are upheld when they are
subjected to hateful and dangerous
rhetoric and ideology
the weapons may be different
but the goals of those who perpetuate
them is often the same
to cause chaos and reduce the ability of
others to defend themselves
to disband communities
to collapse the Collective Strength of
countries who work together
but we have an opportunity here to
ensure that these particular weapons of
war do not become an established part of
warfare
in these times I'm acutely aware of how
easy it is to feel disheartened
we are facing many battles can we get
the point of many fronts and it's quite
chilling actually so she's she's talking
about
misinformation as a weapon of War so
it's what she's what she's urging on a
global international scale
is that misinformation be treated as an
act of War
where does that take us
What's um
what privileges does that Grant then if
they can treat it as an act of War now I
think we we missed the point
sometimes
when we engage with this and like we we
argue that well
climate change skepticism that's not
misinformation so what you're saying
there is that if you're skeptical about
climate change or about man-made climate
change or if you're skeptical at any
level at all even if you're willing to
say that way okay of course climate
change exists climates change we all
know that no one denies it uh do human
beings contribute to it to some extent I
mean everything contributes to it to
some extent you might say so maybe to
some extent uh but I I don't agree
necessarily
with all of the dramatic claims that
you're making about this
so but but even that
is uh that's misinformation
like a kind of qualified skepticism
is misinformation
she's saying that's what everyone on the
left says
and often we will respond to that by by
trying to prove that no it's not
misinformation you're wrong about that
that Almost Doesn't Matter
so the real Point here is that the
government
cannot be in the business
of controlling information
of of declaring what is legitimate
information and what is not
um controlling what people believe
that's what they actually want to do
they want to get inside your head and
tell you what you should believe about
the world
and what you should not believe
and they want to go one step further and
say well if they want to criminalize
they want to criminalize certain beliefs
that's the idea here
and if they can control the information
if we uh if we allow them to seize
control of information and criminalize
certain forms of information then they
control everything because we live in
the information age
you control the information you control
the world
and that's really the point here
yesterday we talked about the problems
with that fake study which supposedly
proved speaking of misinformation actual
misinformation so it was that fake study
supposedly proving that uh quote gender
affirming double mastectomies are good
for minors and we went through all the
problems with it you know the study
comes along just in the nick of time as
we've been as so-called Top surgery for
minors has come under intense scrutiny
and in in Tennessee we're working
towards Banning double mastectomies for
minors
and just in the nick of time CBS reports
and other media Outlets picked up this
um peer-reviewed study which supposedly
proves that actually this is good for
minors we went over the problems with
the study I mean it's it's and and the
problems are almost too numerous to
count I mean for one thing it just to
review the study was funded by a
hospital it was funded and conducted by
a hospital that itself conducts double
mastectomies on liners
so they have a financial stake so
they're they're trying to prove that
what they're already doing is legitimate
and good
um so that's a problem
they they did the follow-up three months
after the fact
which is when three months later three
months after a significant life choice
has been made that is when regret is
least likely
because right at three months you know
especially for something like this right
at three months that's a that's that's
when
you know the uh the the victim as I say
we're not even calling him patients
victims it's when the victim is starting
to you know is really starting to
recover physically so they're feeling a
little bit better and it's not but it's
not nearly enough time for them to have
reflected on what they did and realize
how they've impacted the rest of their
life
it's not enough time for that
so they cut off the study right at three
months
and then also they uh
mysteriously there were people who
dropped out of the study
and so therefore didn't count towards
the final results
they don't explain what does it mean
that they dropped out
what happened to them they don't explain
that
it's reasonable to assume that the
people who dropped out of the study that
would be girls who got the surgery and
then stopped responding and didn't
didn't fill out any surveys or anything
like that after the fact
is it because they regretted it
so that among other problems but then
Jesse singall has has this so there was
a another really fundamental issue with
the study that I didn't even notice
so he tweets this
the study which just came out showing
that Top surgery Works quote unquote
after a three-month follow-up what was
based in part on this 17 item chest
dysphoria scale
after getting surgery the kids CDs
scores went down
but the scale largely measures whether
you have breasts that cause you
discomfort
so this is apparently recorded Jesse
singall
the actual survey
um that these girls were were told to
fill out and this is what they used in
the study
measuring their chest dysphoria
and what they found or you know what
they found is that
um a girl is less likely to have
dysphoria about her breasts if she
doesn't have them
and then that's what they're declaring
in the study but listen to what listen
to uh
the actual items on this chest dysphoria
scale this is what it says
um
one I like looking at my chest in the
mirror
and then they're they're asked to sort
of write each of these statements on a
certain scale
two taking a shower slash bath is
difficult because I have to see my chest
three I avoid going to the beach and or
swimming in public because of my chest
I get gendered as female because of my
chest
dating slash forming intimate
Partnerships is more difficult because
of my chest
physical intimacy sexual activity is
difficult because of my chest
I have struggled to make future plans
because of my chest
I avoid exercise because of my chest
I avoid shopping buying clothing because
of my chest I avoid seeking medical care
because of my chest I feel like my life
has not started because of my chest I
avoid swimming in private places because
of my chest I have to buy slash wear
certain clothes because of my chest
um I I sleep with a binder at night I
avoid using locker rooms because of my
chest I worry that people are looking at
my chest I participate in light in life
less than others because of my chest so
you see what they're doing here
I mean many of these questions several
of them anyway
it's like any any girl or any woman
could answer yes to I I buy certain
clothing because of my chest so so if
you if you buy a bra if you're a woman
and you buy a bra then already you're on
the chest dysphoria scale just by simply
buying a bra then you count at least a
little bit towards you are on the chest
dysphoria Spectrum according to this
because of the fact that you buy a bra
um if you get gendered as female because
of your chest
according to this then you're you're on
the Spectrum for chest is fourth you
have a little bit of justice for you
and then most of the rest of it is just
you know these are things that
many girls deal with
as they're growing through puberty and
they're getting older and their bodies
are changing
male and female as you go through
puberty your body changes it could it
changes in ways you didn't expect or
didn't anticipate
um and so you feel to a certain extent
sort of not at home in your body
that's all very normal
I think it's probably uh it's those
feelings are more intense among among
girls and they are among boys because
the changes are more significant and
severe
um and affect your life more
but all of that is normal
and so what they're doing here is
they're taking these normal feelings
that anyone would feel
and uh
they're categorizing that as a symptom
of chest dysphoria
foreign
which not only for them proves that
after the fact that the top surgery was
the right thing to do but it also has
the effect of suggesting so part of the
idea here is if you give this uh this
survey to a girl before she has the top
surgery then it's a way of suggesting to
her hey by the way you might want to
look into this
because she'll go down that list and say
yes yeah well that applies to me that
applies to me that applies to me well I
guess I need to chop my breasts off
that's the idea that's what they're
going for
all right
uh
let's see it's one other thing I wanted
to mention
this is from the daily wire it says
stranger things Star Caleb McLaughlin
told a group over the weekend that some
fans of the show are racist because they
wouldn't take pictures with him during
the first season
in a video that surfaced on Twitter on
Sunday the 20 year old actor said at the
heroes Comic-Con Belgium but he dealt
with racism early in his career after
being the only black kid on the series
McLaughlin said it definitely took a
toll on me as a younger kid my very
first Comic-Con some people didn't stand
in my line because I was black
some people told me like oh I didn't
want to be in line because you were mean
to 11. even now some people don't follow
me or don't support me because I'm black
he also shared that sometimes overseas
you'll feel the racism the bigotry
sometimes it's hard to talk about and
for people to understand but when I was
younger it definitely affected me a lot
but there's more so the evidence that he
was a victim of racism is that when he
went to Comic-Con
um there were more there weren't as many
people in his line as in other lines and
he knows it's because of racism
he continues um
let's see
he also says at another point I'm trying
to find the exact quote here but he also
talks about how uh he has fewer
Instagram followers than than some of
his co-stars
oh he says why do I have the least
amount of followers I'm on the same show
as everybody from season one my parents
had to be like it's the sad truth but
it's because you're the black child on
the show
so he has 15 million followers on
Instagram
his 15 million followers on Instagram
with it which is less than some people
on the show but more than others and
according to him he said to his parents
hey Mom and Dad I only have 15 million
Instagram followers and his parents said
to him yeah it's because you're black
it's you're a victim of racism that's
what it is
if you weren't black then you'd have you
know you have 30 million followers
this is
uh
Hollywood actors they just they
absolutely love accusing their own fans
of racism this is what they love to do
more than anything and it is seriously
every week now there's another one of
these
and on top of that it also appears that
they're all mind readers
so when he's at Comic-Con and there are
fewer and he looks over at one line and
there's a few more people in it and he
can look and he can read all their minds
and tell that the reason they're not in
his line is that they hate black people
makes a lot of sense
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
ojh says I'm 26 almost 27 when I look
back on my teen years and early 20s I'm
continuously shocked at the difference
in my ability to make decisions and
predict outcomes it's actually kind of
frightening to get over that hump and
realize your teenage decisions were
basically all shots in the dark yeah I'm
glad you said uh early 20s because
that's important too we have 18
so we talk about
how grotesque and horrible it is to do
this to to kids who are under the age of
18 and it is
but even above the age of 18. so 18 is
kind of this imaginary cutoff date but
when it comes to psychological and
emotional development
um even at the age of 18 there is still
quite a lot of work that needs to be
done
into your early 20s
I mean I I myself can look I can I can
look back at myself in my early 20s and
say I don't even know it's it's might as
well be a different person's life that's
how different I am from that person
and I am not the only
you know adult who can say that so it's
a very very common to feel that way in
fact you know if you if you don't feel
that way if you're in your 30s or 40s
and you don't feel that way when you
look back at yourself when you're in
your early 20s either you were
uncommonly uh mature which is possible
or uh you haven't matured at all which
is a problem
but you're exactly right
um really to I mean to do this to anyone
but including in your early 20s is
horrific
let's see
uh lftr says the cutoff date for the
study tells all to gauge regret on a
lifelong decision you must allow for a
substantial amount of time to elapse in
order for the permanence of the choice
to set in just about everyone can
intuitively gauge that one year is
probably the very lowest cutoff to
attempt to observe regret on a decision
in which the entire rest of your life is
the window for the condition to manifest
if the study chose a six-month cut off
this would be highly suspect at three
months you are likely right around the
time of being completely healed from the
surgery the feeling of normalcy on the
recovery standpoint can alone can fully
displace any potential for feelings of
regret about the choice this is
literally the time frame at which the
regret is least likely and very
obviously the reason they chose this
nearly instantaneous cutoff for this for
the study they might as well have asked
if they regretted the surgery before
they underwent it
right exactly they might as well ask the
next day
um
let's see
Jesse Miller says it looks like Matt's
office is located in the middle of a
Hawaiian jungle plus the weather never
changes we'll get to the bottom of this
come winter this is my protest against
climate change right there behind me see
it every day
uh let's see another one says Dude
Perfect is a YouTube channel for kids
they do trick shots pranks and sports
content they're awesome they're
Christian and a great influence on kids
my sister went to a show and they prayed
and did the devotional at the end
for the kids that some of them have
probably never even heard of The Gospel
get into it Matt yeah I got a lot of
Dude Perfect defenses in the comments I
never criticized Dude Perfect by the way
I was just I have no idea who they are
I've never heard of them at all sounds
like they're great never heard of them
um simply trying to make a point about
the fracturing of culture and how kids
kids these days have in entirely their
own culture their own celebrities their
own pop culture scene everything all to
themselves which we we tend to take for
granted because you know we take for
granted anything that started happening
yesterday we take for granted as just
inevitable and we assume it's always
been this way but that's not the case
um at least it shouldn't be
let's see Anne says I want to take you
seriously about your Crusade against
genital mutilation but can you continue
to ignore the most common form
circumcision there's not any point in
trying to ban genital mutilation if
you're going to make an exception for
that
um
I find this point that I hear sometimes
exceptionally annoying and and
ridiculous
and you're also it's you're doing a big
favor to the left and maybe that's your
point maybe that's what you're trying to
do
but this is exactly an analogy that they
want to make
in fact there was someone I think it was
a Tennessee lawmaker yesterday on
Twitter said that our attempts to uh ban
these things in Tennessee is a is an
infringement on on the religious freedom
of Jews because she's drawing a
comparison between circumcision and
um an actual castration
so that so when you do that that's
exactly what they want they want to say
oh it's either two exactly the same
things so if you're if you're fine with
one you should be fine with the other
but of course they're not the same thing
at all
okay can you see the difference between
circumcision the removal of foreskin and
the removal of the entire sex organ
can you not agree that there's a
distinction to be made between those two
things
foreign
I don't know how else to explain it I
mean if it's not self-evident to you
that these are two vastly different
things than um no matter how you feel
about circumcision you can be opposed to
it it's fine but it's it's just not at
all the same
um
Joshua says Matt I can't agree with you
on your final topic these days companies
will take advantage of you if you let
them boundaries are important
and for most people they can put in all
they can put in all the effort in the
world but it doesn't translate to
Greater success
well yes as I said boundaries are
important in the workplace boundaries
are important everywhere in your life
right
um
but the skill right is isn't how you set
those boundaries
because if you're just running into the
situation side back off everyone leave
me alone like anyone can do that
that's that's you know that's gonna
backfire especially in a work
environment
and especially when you're talking to
your employers the people who are paying
you giving you a paycheck you just you
can't talk to them that way you can't
talk to everyone however you want it's
just not how it works
and when they have something you need
which is like a paycheck they have
leverage over you and part of being an
adult is to un that doesn't mean doesn't
mean you just do everything they say and
you're their slave no
but part of being an adult is
understanding this
you know understanding who has leverage
and where your Leverage is and how to
use it and how to use it in a way that's
not going to backfire
so setting boundaries with tact is is
the uh is the key there
as far as you say most people can put in
all the effort in the world but it
doesn't translate to Greater success I I
don't know where you're getting that
from like what where how have you
arrived at that conclusion
and it seems to me that we've got a lot
of people who arrive at this conclusion
almost immediately upon entering the
Working World and that's the issue you
just got there and you've already
decided that no matter how hard you work
uh it's it's not going to matter how
could you possibly know that I mean you
can only know that if you if you work
your absolute hardest for years and
years and years and years and then you
look back and find that you did not
climb up the ladder at all
okay well then we have something to talk
about
but what that's going to tell me is that
you're you know maybe you're in the
wrong line of work you're working for
the wrong company
in most cases you know it's uh there are
people who just get lucky there are
people who are born with silver spoons
and all of that but in in most cases
when you look at the people you know you
look at people in a certain field and
there are some who have had a lot of
success and others who have had a
moderate amount of success and others
who have had no success and and and you
you can find there's there's a you know
it's it's easy to understand there's a
pattern here
and the people who've had the most
success have put in a lot more effort
than the ones who have had none that's
usually the way it works
well if you haven't heard yet Candace
Owens is back from maternity leave with
a Vengeance her brand new show Candace
Owens is available now on daily wire
plus and takes on the big topics of the
day uncovers lies it exposes the
hypocrisy and news and politics and you
know it's going to be done in typical
Candace style fearless and Resolute this
is everything you love about Candace and
now she's streaming five days a week
you'll not want to miss it trust me when
I say it is huge so watch Candace Owens
uh now on daily wire Plus or listen on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts also make sure you
join me today at 4 P.M Central for an
all access live I'll be answering your
questions about the trans movement that
is currently invading our country so
that's again going to be uh today at
four o'clock at dailywire.com discuss
and is that it it is it now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
as a frequent flyer myself who also
experiences intense flying anxiety I
have developed very specific emotional
needs while in the air
um now I've long since learned to
suppress my physical needs while flying
like like all other air Travelers I've
grown accustomed to being treated like
poultry stuffed in a cage and strapped
onto the back of a semi barreling down
the highway everything is cramped
there's no room to move around or
stretch your legs there's no concern for
your comfort on Spirit Airlines you know
the analogy becomes quite literal
because on spirit in particular the only
snack they give you and this is true is
they give you a handful of chicken feed
which the flight attendants toss in your
lap as they walk down the aisle scowling
at you of course if you if you eat the
chicken feed then it's an up charge of
43 dollars a person I think this is the
modern flying experience you sit there
miserable neglected squish between a
sumo wrestler and someone's emotional
support llama unless you fly first class
of course in which case you will enjoy
the decadent luxury of being treated
like a human being rather than livestock
In First Class you can engage in Wild
Flights of Fancy such as uh bending your
knee and moving your elbow
In First Class the flight attendants
will even mostly suppress their disdain
for you which is nice and there are
other perks too like in first class the
airline does you the favor of making
sure there's actually enough room in the
overhead compartment for the carry-on
baggage they said you could bring on the
plane as opposed to the coach experience
where half of the people have to check
their bags which they will likely never
see again that's just how it goes and
this is why I have lowered my standards
and reduced my list of needs and
expectations to really just one item
and as it's an emotional thing for the
sake of my emotional well-being I only
ask that the flight attendants do not
appear visibly startled by turbulence
because even a slightly raised eyebrow
or a barely audible whoa is to me a
signal that we all face certain death
so until today my point is that that was
that was the one meager favor that I
asked of the flight crew
but now it seems I must add one more
item to the list
because I also ask that the pilot does
not cross-dress while flying
I do not want to be an unwilling
participant in a drag show 35 000 feet
in the air
which is why I will certainly never fly
Virgin Atlantic not that I ever would
have flown them anyway to be fair but
here's the story from CNN it says Virgin
Atlantic has said that it is scrapping
gendered uniform options in an effort to
Champion the individuality of its
employees the British Airline announced
in a press release on Wednesday that
cabin crew pilots and ground staff can
select which uniform they feel most
comfortable in no matter their gender
gender identity or gender expression
optional pronoun badges will also become
available for for crew and passengers uh
Juha jarvanin whose Virgin Atlantic's
Chief commercial officer said in the
press release the company believes it's
important to encourage people to embrace
their individuality and be their true
selves at work
jarvanin added it is for that reason
that we want to allow our people to wear
the uniform that best suits them and how
they identify and ensure our customers
are addressed by their preferred
pronouns
now if this seems a bit unsettling to
you don't worry uh because CNN quote say
judge from RuPaul's Drag Race who says
that this is all a very good thing
and obviously there could be no better
Authority on proper standards of conduct
and air travel than a judge from
RuPaul's Drag Race
at least according to CNN quote myself
Visage who's a Michelle Visage a judge
on RuPaul's Drag Race All-Stars who
showcased the uniform alongside staff
welcome the move quote as the mother of
a non-binary child and as an ally to the
lgbtq plus Community these efforts by
Virgin Atlantic to further inclusivity
for its people are extremely important
and personal to me she said in the press
release people feel empowered when
they're wearing what best represents
them and this gender identity policy
allows people to embrace who they are
and bring their full selves to work
Virgin Atlantic said the changes are
part of a wider initiative under its be
yourself agenda
well this is great you know especially
when coupled with the news from earlier
in the year that airlines are lowering
their recruiting requirements for Pilots
so as to create a more diverse and
Equitable Workforce so what that means
is that you're racially diverse
genderqueer pansexual drag queen pilot
who goes by the name Captain hot pants
or something may not be the best
equipped to fly the aircraft but at
least he's being himself
so you can
[Music]
here's the here's the commercial by the
way let's just pause and watch this
commercial this is an airline commercial
[Music]
you watch this and tell me you want to
fly this Airline this is what you want
foreign
[Music]
Atlantic see the world differently well
they certainly are delivering on that
promise anyway
as you're as you know you you can take
comfort at least as your uh
plane is nose diving into the Pacific
you can take take comfort in the fact
that your pilot lived by his truth and
now he's dying by it and he's taking all
of you with him which is which is really
an honor I guess
now I'm only being slightly facetious
here I actually do appreciate this move
by Virgin Atlantic for two reasons okay
so for one thing
if the uh if the captain of my plane is
emotionally and mentally unstable I want
to know that ahead of time I actually
want him to advertise that and there's
no better way for him to advertise it
than by dressing in Drag
of course this only works to the
passenger's Advantage if the pilot
announces it prior to departure and if
the passengers who value their lives are
then given an opportunity to de-board
so it sounds something like this like hi
folks from the flight deck this is your
captain speaking I will be taking off in
about 10 minutes after a short taxi down
the runway also I am personally wearing
a skirt for this evening's flight uh my
father didn't love me and so this is
what I'm doing now I'll tell you more
about it when we're in the air thanks
for flying with us
so if there was an announcement like
that I mean it could work out to
everybody's Advantage but I don't think
that's how it will work on Virgin
Atlantic so I suppose this potential
positive is negated but there is still
this
that the whole stunt exposes the utter
inanity and absurdity of the left's
notion of individuality
because first of all this is not really
individuality at all when a man
cross-dresses he is not inventing a new
style or doing something nobody's ever
done before he is rather embracing a
different style one that is ugly and
disordered but he didn't create it this
is not something that originates in the
depths of his being it originates in the
culture the culture has told him that
this is a fashionable Brave laudable way
to dress and behave he is in fact
conforming this is why you'll notice
that drag queens though they are
supposed to be fierce individualists all
end up looking exactly the same it's
almost like there's a drag queen uniform
which happens to be modeled after early
90s Tim Burton films for whatever reason
this is true too of people who Endeavor
to be non-binary or androgynous in their
style of dress they all end up looking
the same right right down to the
hairstyle and the facial piercings
there is a much much greater and more
vibrant and interesting variety of
styles among men who dress like men and
women who dress like women than there
are among men and women who Endeavor to
break through these binary categories
they all end up looking like clones
created in the back of a Hot Topic or
something
second
even though all of this be yourself
stuff is basically a sham
and modern culture's notion of an
individual is far more rigid and
restricting than ever
we also see here why individuality and
being oneself are not the ideal in every
situation or even in most situations
because to be an adult in a civilized
society means controlling your impulses
and conforming yourself to certain
standards of conduct
as you go about your day you find
yourself in different roles you know all
kinds of roles as employee as customer
as neighbor as parent as spouse some of
these roles are situational some endure
and maintain every day all day through
your whole life but each role is
accompanied by expectations and
responsibilities
things you're supposed to do and not do
say and not say whether you like it or
not
so you uh bring your full self into each
role in a physical and literal sense but
there may be aspects of your personality
okay there may be um inclinations or
preferences or predilections you have
which are not appropriate and should not
be expressed or engaged in given the
role or circumstance
so if you walk through life declaring
that you're going to be yourself
everywhere all the time meaning that
you'll simply do whatever you want not
respecting any standards or
acknowledging any expectations that
everything in your life quickly breaks
down
and you begin to fail in every role and
thus in life itself
nowhere could this be more obvious than
in the context of air travel
because when we are in a metal tube 35
000 feet in the air hurtling along at
600 miles an hour
it isn't the place for anyone to be
their true selves or Express themselves
individually
nobody like I don't want anyone on the
plane doing that
given the stakes and the consequences if
things go wrong and given that we're all
stuck in close proximity to each other
and that none of us can immediately exit
the situation without suffering rather
significant consequences
um an airplane is then a place for
decorum and professionalism
I want very little personal expression
from the person sitting next to me even
less do I want it from the pilot
none of us are on the plane in order so
that we can get to know the captain on
an intimate and personal level none of
us are interested in his true self
that's not why we pay exorbitant sums to
board the aircraft
we don't want the pilot to express
himself we want him to express the plane
from point A to point B and that's it
we simply want to arrive at our
destination
we want the flight crew to get us there
as quickly and safely as possible and
with little as little drama as possible
I'm flamboyant individualism has never
kept a plane in the sky
engineering and physics is what keeps
the plane in the sky along with the
expertise of professionalism on the part
of the people in the cockpit
so that should be the focus
and I shouldn't have to say this but
this is also why you should not be
cross-dressing while flying the plane
that is also why Virgin Atlantic is
today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]